foreign
[Applause]
foreign
hey
dong welcome my friends to uh Batman be
on the final Batman Beyond of 2022 this
wretched year I'm Kevin Smith and I am
Mark Bernard hey oh uh welcome kids this
is where it all comes to an end
that's it this is the moment you've been
waiting for you're like I want this to
stop it's about to stop you're about to
get what you wanted all year long you
were like
to end sayonara freaks then does not
uh I hope everyone had a wonderful
Christmas Kwanzaa Hanukkah
um whatever you celebrate man what about
those who worship the devil what did
they do some Pagan ritual good for you
cats too the same thing they do every
day Kevin try to take over the world
hopefully something Jolly
um how were your holidays Mark uh mine
were mine were good I avoided uh what
sounded like travel op travel apocalypse
2022 even though I was on a plane on
Christmas day
um I had taken my son to Minneapolis
he is a big Minnesota Vikings fan so we
went for his Christmas present to go see
a Minnesota Vikings home football game
in Minneapolis Minnesota where it was
negative five degrees for most of the
time oh yeah that's a that's a father's
love right there that this that's a
stick what I know of you I'm not going
to say I know you like I know myself but
when all the time we've known each other
you've never mentioned sports ball once
so I can't imagine but you were sitting
there like go sports ball
um well given that I know you as well as
I know you mentioning sports ball would
get me no purchase
they're blankly blinking like are you a
sports ball Enthusiast of some sort uh I
am a sports ball Enthusiast uh do you
have a secret life do you have a layer
that I don't know about share with me
because you don't think I can handle it
well when we're looking to like all
paint our chests and go to the football
you know sports ball stadium I figure
I'll think Kevin's down for the chess
painting I'll call the other guys I
don't know I like cosplay as much as the
next person
that's like death the black racer or
something like that
you're the sports character of sorts I
would love that
that was a comic book a Marvel book
wasn't it I feel like you know maybe
Flash Gordon's as a quarterback of the
New York Jets is the closest interaction
the cross the Venn diagram between you
know our two twin loves it's weird that
I identified more with Dale Arden than
anybody else I went right to the
cheerleader mode you really did get down
match him like this yeah I think some
sort of barbaric game
that's awesome that's colitis right
there colitis on board
so wait how was the how was the sports
ball game in Minnesota
the sports ball game was was wonderful
it was delightful
um all the more so by being with the kid
absolutely that's that's that was the
true gift I could not have cared who won
or lost and my team lost but uh it was
that the boy got to have this experience
and I got to have it with him and so
that was lovely
so sweet
um I saw my mom I spent it with uh Mom
yay absolutely lovely uh as well uh you
were not impacted by the travel woes
that seemed to have been impacting much
of the nation I drove like most of the
year I've spent in a car because of the
uh clerks 3 the convenience tour so I
was kind of programmed to drive and
drive I did and uh Josh and I took a
ride and it was uh
it was long it was right there by the by
the you know everyone traveling well
there occurred to me that a lot of
people might draw
they were bad excellent
uh let me show you let me introduce you
to a couple come in here kids
um here at the secret stash you run into
all
uh sorts of folks that you've you've
been intimate with in the past look at
it look at how they framed up so nice
and they just moved into their marks as
if there were marks well done kids cat
and David here man uh hey happy Holidays
happy holidays everybody so uh we have
been intimate with each other
would you like me to explain how it's
very no no I don't
um
uh I married these two good Folks at
smodcast oh
yeah one of the only photos that hangs
in this mod castle that not me or mine
there's about a minute too because I'm
because I'm overseeing the wedding so I
guess it's perfect
um but look at that this this proof
right here that if Kevin Smith marries
you it sticks how long you been married
kids 18 years well yeah technically
[Music]
so it was like family ties and then you
guys just got married
was that what they did the keatons were
common law married they had never
actually got married married
uh yeah well Pennsylvania did away with
common law so
living in sin for a long time
yeah man [ __ ] look at you Kevin Smith
y'all by the Jersey let me ask you this
man yeah
you just really blew my mind the keatons
weren't married on that show no
somebody gotta fact check this
very special episode where they sat the
kids down they're like we never
officially got married I I wish yeah I'm
pretty sure that like at some point Alex
P like discovered this and was Furious
because he was a bastard in some fashion
like he was born out of wedlock
wow that's great man I was going I was I
went into show Cannon where I was like
was that Meredith Baxter Bernie's
character's real name yeah
um but look at this these kids they were
just happening through the stash and
here they are as you might have guessed
we are at Giants secrets to say again
uh look at this
is yeah come on over kids thank you
David and Jeff
more kids that are just rolling by the
store tell them your story what's your
name Come Close Come Close get in the
light what's your name Caitlin and what
is this a shower this is my baby shower
this is the baby shower yeah
um is this first baby first baby
um you know it's gonna be
yeah do you know what the name is gonna
be that's what I'm not saying oh look at
that Secrets um look at that life like
within life she's alive obviously but
there's life within her man and she
you're where are you going like you must
be doing something cooler than this no
that's all I wanted to do Roll by the
stash thanks
hey they're open at seven you guys are
adorable and so what this is the daddy
wow
so this is what happens at the secret
stash man like
life within life and whatnot get people
getting married people having babies
like it's like a small town hospital
it's like our time this is Thornton
Wilder up in this spot
um what a pleasure I should let's take a
picture I'm gonna take a picture okay
you do you have the camera let me move
this [ __ ] out of the way
meanwhile Vamp Mark Vamp
well oh thanks I I almost hate to do
this while Kevin's not on screen right
now
but so I did some Wikipedia looking up
about uh about our friends from Family
Ties and yeah
Elise Donnelly Keaton married her
husband
Stephen
while in college at Berkeley in 1964. I
knew I you don't know
you gaslighting piece of [ __ ] I knew you
were wrong well then where did I get
that from
you're making your own shop which I'll
be honest with you was a pretty
fascinating show but I knew head Ken and
I knew their American opening credits
they're getting married the kids are are
young I think but here come on in so
this is uh we're gonna uh give our
pregnant friend here a bathrobe to go
home with sign about bathrobe jump in
here oh my sure it looks like could it
have been Family Matters
I don't think so
I don't think so
if you bring your your unborn child here
James I'm Bob Seger says you will get a
bathrobe for free
um congratulations thank you so much you
had such a pleasure
oh
don't charge her for that
I'm trying to figure out where the [ __ ]
I that came across my
like was it Gary David Goldberg the
Creator who was in a criminal marriage
somehow I had wedded Family Ties and
common law marriage all I know is that
like I go to Black Panther to and post a
picture of me crying [ __ ] internet
melts down you lit [ __ ] all over the
legacy of family
by making these two hippies like total
[ __ ] who never got married in the show
and I will gallivant for the rest of my
life on the internet unscathed
you saw Bob's secret stash as you can
see and um
of course that means
kev's Comics look at all those Comics uh
masquerade and quick stops quick stops
number three comes out this week can I
show you some covers Mark please do okay
uh so this cover here is by uh my good
buddy Eric fluger look at that
it's an Elias oriented his work is so
intricate he's been featured on
Hollywood Babylon a lot in the past but
look at that Elias as a Transformer man
and mubi is Jesus and there's crypto up
there
[ __ ] cover is a work of art God damn
it
um and inside of course is black and
white story and it's a story about uh
oh those two copies it's a story about
uh
uh Elias and pillow pads and stuff
really good uh the other cover and this
cover is astounding as well man two like
two incredibly intricate covers this is
by Mark gonye I believe he said this was
his first cover it's this cover like it
looks like this and it's a series of
little boxes but those little boxes
literally it's the entire story of
Clerks 2 frame by frame
it tells the whole movie story it's
[ __ ] fascinating such a great piece
man and then the secret stash exclusive
cover drawn by comic book men's own Walt
Flanagan man my boy Walt Flanagan uh
since this issue is about pillow print
pants the [ __ ] troll he drew
what pillow pants would look like so
this is the secret stash exclusive cover
of quick stops number three man
impressive look at pillow oh there it is
look at how adorable that is
that's something uh quick stops number
three comes out this week I believe
hey it's next week thank you Sarah thank
you January 4th so the you know new year
begins Quick Stop number three is out
however here at the secret stash
we got it out next week
are you serious
so the kids
there's Matt and Sarah
the kids just took kids yeah you're tiny
in the back kids just told me that we
got a double drop on January foot I mean
this is ostensibly a show about Comics
so let me talk about Comics but for a
minute in a comic book store we have a
drop secret stash press so quick stops
number three and masquerade four comes
out
that's a big day good day to be a fan of
Kevin Smith Comics I'll tell you that
you haven't checked him out because you
guys hey congrats kids
um if you haven't checked them out get
your hands on get your hands on them
I dare you uh bath man
let's hear about your holidays you got a
baby and Christmas is all about baby
where's your Christmas it was awesome uh
she doesn't quite get everything but she
knows that she really likes opening
presents
we got her a little trampoline
she was really into that in a little
play kitchen she's re she's still really
into that
and part of the gift part of the gift
was for you to dress up like mcu's
Quicksilver
that's what you look like in your little
box I was like oh quicksilver's here man
this was uh I think Jen's trying to add
color into my life this was a Christmas
gift she's trying to she's trying to
make you a thing tell her to stop trying
to make Banff man happen
fetch baby fetch remember that moment in
Wanda Vision when she was like uh you
know she mentioned Ultra and she's like
you killed your brother didn't he
or didn't Ultron kill your brother and
she was like what did you say was that
this year or last year
thinking was last year
was one division last year check it out
man uh one division was 2021.
well we ain't here to talk about 2021
because it's 2022 about to go into books
and we're here to talk about that before
we say damn thing about it we gotta uh
pay our bills man and the good folks
uh at native
native deodorant nativedeo.com and they
are responsible for tonight's episode
love or hate tonight's episode
don't blame me or Mark blame the good
folks native deodorant Men smell and
feel fresh all day long with data get 20
off your first order by going to
nativedeo.com Fatman or simply use the
promo code Fatman at checkout that's
native
deo-d-e-o.com slash famine or use the
promo code Fatman checkout for 20 off
your first order we love native this is
the last ad what we're gonna do in 2022.
this is it I ain't doing another ad this
year I'm done so you can't get another
ad out of me this year I won't do it so
this is it this is the final ad of 2022
and and let me tell you something these
native folks they've stuck by us
relentlessly uh every time we're doing a
show their name pops up man like a
wonderful sponsor
I reward them by literally buying native
in the real world I don't wait for him
to send me to free stuff like Mark I go
out I spend my ad dollars on Native
product in the wild man because I want
to smell fresh when it comes to personal
hygiene who has time to read that long
list of ingredients on the back of the
bottle not me I'm doing shows some
ingredients I can't even pronounce if
you're like me and you care about what
goes on your body and then it's time to
try native personal care products like I
did meant every native product is
Thoroughly formulated to keep you
feeling and smelling fresh
all day long you know native for their
aluminum free deodorant man native keeps
their ingredients list bare naked the
ingredients you understand like coconut
oil shea butter and baking soda man
native deodorant checks a lot of boxes a
72-hour odor protection naturally
derived ingredients is the residue free
application native also offers a variety
of scents with new and limited edition
scents being released all the time take
it away Mark when you use native you
will smell amazing all day long thanks
to their long lasting scents want to
smell spicy and woodsy or clean and
fresh native has a scent up a scent
option for everyone warm Saturn cinnamon
sounds wonderful cashmere and rain oh
yes please toasted marshmallow and
vanilla Wildwood and cardamom come on
now so Now's the Time to make the switch
from an antiperspirant to Native when
you visit their site you can discover
all their fresh scents and maybe even
try one out on their body washes that's
good how you're at it so smelling smell
and feel fresh all day along with Native
get 20 off your first order by going to
nativedeo.com Fatman or use promo code
Fatman at checkout that's nativedeo.com
Fatman use promo code fat minute
checkout for 20 off your first order
thank you to the good folks in Native
Deo
dot com we love Native Native seems to
like us at least you think Deo stands
for Department of extraordinary odors
yes I think it's exact and if it doesn't
it does now I'm a Deo agent Mr Brett
Khan did you you watch Rick and Morty uh
I am starting
for the first time it's amazing the show
is flat out brilliant but they did an
episode uh in the last cycle the first
episode of the last cycle that just went
up that it's a like a kind of follow-up
to an episode they did last season that
is every writer's like dream because
it's just filled with writing jokes it's
all about it's all about story
it's so so damn good
um I'll wait till you get there I mean
you could jump out of order it don't
matter but
you will absolutely adore it yeah one
final point they're running past
something that says trials they're
looking for somebody he's like and more
he's like did he go that way and Rick's
like no if he goes that way he becomes a
hero
um so damn good
um how are you what have you seen
anything did you see Babylon yet I have
not seen Babylon yet I uh I I I we might
watch it tonight because I don't know if
you know this
or not
I own a movie theater uh so uh we're
gonna uh watch it tonight at uh smod
Castle Cinemas that's tonight because
tomorrow night we're doing an evening a
New Year's evening with Kevin
uh which uh I I wanted to you know
normally when we do Babylon
uh improv's like a 200 seater and so I
was like man if we can get to like 150
because we don't have a bar you know
bar to go to the Empire I've got a bar
so you can get drunken listen to me I'm
waiting not yet
yes that sounded ominous Quicksilver
dashed in here said something ominous
and dashed out look out for Ultron
um so it's uh we we hit rang the bell
hit 200 we're at I think 203 right now
are you know are like absolute sellout
for the room is like 220 or something
so I was hoping to hit 200 and we did
I'm very very delighted so we'll be
doing a show tomorrow if you want to
join us folks there's still a few
tickets left go to
smartcastlecinemas.com watch New Year's
Eve with Kevin Smith JC information up
there before uh so I'm gonna watch
Babylon tonight I I you know and I've
got I understand it was a hot topic on
Twitter the other day
um I saw Margo
Robbie Roby uh trending and when I see
somebody trending I'm always like did
they pass away and she's very much alive
but she was being roasted Alive by some
of Twitter for like you know that movie
not doing well and I'm like how is that
her fault
she might direct this
um but I look forward to seeing it man
it sounds
sounds big and expensive and long yeah I
I had but so many three-hour movies in
me and I'm like well I took it out of
you Avatar took it out of me you know I
watched uh I watched wakanda forever
again and that clock's in like 2 45 and
like I think I need what's a good 90
minute movie you know what is clerks
three it's a good 90 minute movie
you damn skippy our little joke one of
the jokes in the movie is Randall's like
uh who is Elias goes what's movie going
to be about and Randall says it'll be
about 90 minutes I hate long music and I
just tried so [ __ ] hard to get the
movie to a 90-minute cut and it would
have hurt it to do so so I think I wound
up at like 93 95 before credits but I
was desperately trying to get it to 90
for that reason alone just to just
somebody be like oh my God Randall he
was right now he didn't
I'm curious about Babylon uh not not
sure when I'm gonna get to it but I'll
get to it it's playing downstairs I pop
my head uh no I'm not down I'm not at
the theater now I'm at the secret State
I own many businesses in New Jersey Mark
I don't know if you know that or not uh
and sometimes I don't know where I am
but when I'm there I say downstairs uh I
was there earlier and I popped my head
in and there was like three people
watching it Puss in Boots is the real
winner man I've heard Puss in Boots is
actually incredible I don't doubt it man
our boy Brian Lynch has worked on a
bunch of them so it may have been like
part his script or something like that
but they work hard over at that uh
what's that place called illumination
yeah is it elimination or is that dream
work
um I think that's elimination
I don't know I I don't want to go out
and say more wrong [ __ ] yeah don't be
family tying this put some boots is uh
he's from Shrek right yeah yeah so
that's a Dreamworks Animation thing
gotcha
I guess yeah let me stop saying [ __ ]
well yeah we're getting a lot yeah man
we're ruining our credibility cop
culture commentator pop culturist Mark
Bernard Banff um can I derail this
conversation for a second
did it have rails to begin with hold on
oh really when I was setting up the show
you're always like oh I I went
downstairs and I watched this on my
movie screen
as I was setting up the show and I'm
gonna ask I'm gonna ask this in a way
that you won't get in trouble
do you ever think about putting porn on
the movie theater screen have you ever
been like wow that would be that would
be a giant
giant like Larger than Life porn that's
a big ass not only have I thought about
putting it up on the screen I thought
about can I sell tickets to it
because as an exhibitor that's all I'm
thinking and if we're selling tickets to
porn can we sell popcorn does the porn
audience buy candy that's the lifeblood
of the theater but in that instance if I
was going to run porn I'd sell tissues
according to the uh the movie Taxi
Driver which I did watch last night they
do in fact sell popcorn and candy in
movie theaters in Times Square in the
1970s so if you're up to recreate the
authentic
um porn smut house experience you would
sell the shittiest popcorn you could
find and we got it we got you a couple
no people love our popcorn they [ __ ]
about our some of our seats but they
love our popcorn because it's fresh pop
and our popcorn machine broke and you
know I'm always like well buy a new one
and Ernie's like there what are you
[ __ ] nuts like they don't sell them
around the block and it's going to take
a while to get it and let me try to fix
it and he fixed it man he [ __ ]
Ernie Ernie O'Donnell runs smart castle
like literally runs it like like [ __ ]
Schneider on one day at a time you know
what I'm saying but he's also
co-ownership but like he puts in so much
[ __ ] time is one thing for him to
like make sure like doors are open on
time people get paid blah blah blah to
fix the [ __ ] popcorn machine you
don't even have those skills now he's
got a whole new set of skills
fam I mean I bet you if you if you
wanted to you could probably get some
vintage print of like deep throat or
Behind the Green Door or some [ __ ] and
like then it becomes or or you just play
it off a laptop bro we're all digital
there man I got me one of the most
expensive projectors coming in Mana
Barco uh comes in like for I guess maybe
a couple months into the next year man
like laser projection high end and
whatnot so all we have to do is Jack in
PornHub and project it writ large and
just go through categories man find one
that like you know we could probably
find one of those categories where they
have depictions of us and sexual
activities and [ __ ] nobody has that for
me but James having Bob I'm sure you'd
be surprised they're probably there's
God look we live in the age of the AI
art generator so while we're doing the
show somebody go over and say Mark
Bernard and Kevin Smith porn and see
what the computer joined don't do that
please don't do it
I mean I believe there are chubby black
dudes on the [ __ ] internet having sex
that would not surprise me but I don't
think it's me I think it's chubby black
dude I'm just flattered that you finally
referred to me as a chubby black dude
I've been waiting for it
so long and finally your Christmas wish
has come true yes God damn it it must be
the holiday
now go buy that boy a nice fat goose
Whip and change at kids
um what do we uh we got some news we
have a tiny bit of news we got two news
items uh and then we have
um the hotly anticipated
um not nearly enough debated but my uh
[ __ ] that I loved in 2022 list
I have some honorable mentions and I
have a top 10 list I like that man uh I
did not prepare one of those but I am
prepared to co-sign the ones on yours
that I like and anything I feel it's
missing I will point out later excellent
oh my God we both put drinks at the same
time and the show went dead
the audience just like you [ __ ] Rubes
it's like how long we've been doing this
10 years should we figure this out yeah
um so you want to do the news first and
then close with the list
yeah let's do the news what news weather
the news weather the news again it was a
it's a slow week between uh Christmas
and New Year's the town is historically
uh shut down by the sun honestly
Hollywood kind of you know puts up the
the closed sign after Thanksgiving but
it is absolutely closed for this week
but there's an interview in the New York
Times in which
um writer director Ryan coogler
explained what the Black Panther 2 story
was going to be before Chadwick Boseman
died
I saw this story uh the other day but I
didn't click on it because something was
going on and I was like oh I want to get
back to that so I'm delighted to hear
this story yeah yeah they uh Ryan
coogler and Joe Robert Cole who co-wrote
both of those films
um again talked to the New York Times uh
last week Friday and explained how the
blip the event between Avengers Infinity
war and endgame that sort of five year
period which wiped out half of every
living thing across space would have
played a key role in the in in Black
Panther too
um the superhero and leader of one of
the world's most powerful Nations was
among those who disappeared and the
challenge was
um what it would mean for him especially
after he lost his own father in the
first film that was the challenge said
Kugler it was absolutely nothing like
what we made it was going to be a
father-son story from the perfect from
the perspective of a father because the
first movie had been a father-son story
from the perspective of the sons
so we learned about t'challa's son
Tucson uh again spoilers for bp2 in case
you haven't seen it but we do learn that
that in that five-year period
um in the span between black panther one
and black panther 2 t'challa and Nikki
had had a son named Toussaint
um but cooler says that audiences would
have been introduced in way earlier with
the film relying on some animation to
help fill in the narrative gaps the
first scene was an animated sequence you
hear Nakia talking to Toussaint she says
tell me what you know about your father
you realize that he doesn't know his dad
was the Black Panther he'd never met him
and the key is remarried to a Haitian
dude Google explains then we cut to
reality and it's the night that
everybody comes back from the blip and
so you see t'challa meet his kid for the
first time
um we had some crazy scenes in there for
Chad our code name for the movie was
summer break and the movie was about a
certain what was about a summer that the
kid spends with his dad for his eighth
birthday the original where they go into
the bush and they have to live off the
land but something happens and the child
has to go save the world with his son on
his hip that was the movie
um
I think uh according to him Neymar was
always the antagonist
um the tone is going to be similar
t'challa was going to be grieving the
loss of time so coming back after being
gone for five years as a man with so
much responsibility to so many coming
back after a force five years absence
that's what the film is tackling he was
grieving the time he couldn't get back
grief was always a big part of what the
Black Panther sequel was going to be
um and that sounds kind of lovely and
like fun in a in a weird sort of way
well very very Lone Wolf in Cub no I
mean a little almost in cubby but I mean
he's an older kid I mean if he's gonna
be like eight or nine it's it's a bit
more you know going have a catch with
Dad and then catch being interrupted by
having to save the world and then
discovering that your dad is a superhero
and what that really means
um but if summer break was the code word
it's like oh that actually sounds kind
of fun right in a weird way even if it
is about you know the the sadness of
having missed the first five years of
that kid's life
um
I don't know it's an interesting peel
peel back into What Might Have Been
which we almost never get
true yeah I mean it certainly wouldn't
get that from Kevin foggy no it's Gotta
came from one of the storytellers
absolutely which apparently it did
um oh God screw this and chat said uh JC
I generated the AI pick of Kevin Mark
romance that they asked for just tweeted
it to you oh no go find it JC you've got
to see what that looks like
God bless us everyone get ready
Christmas is a post-christmas miracle oh
Jesus uh and our second news item is not
a particularly big one but it is that
Avatar 2 has officially crossed the 1
billion Mark worldwide
yeah
it has been and it did it what faster
than any other movie in history it did
it 14 days it will ride release
um wave water now has bragging rights to
being the fastest to 1 billion since
Spider-Man no way home and the fastest
to the mark in 2022 uh it has also
become the only the sixth film ever to
cross a billion in its first two weeks
of release and the fourth Disney
released to do so
um so a bunch of accolades even if they
are somewhat like it's the the fastest
to do it in 2022 it's the fastest to a
billion since Spider-Man three
um nevertheless a billion dollars is
nothing to [ __ ] sneeze at so congrats
to all parties concerned and you know
remember just not like 10 10 days ago we
were seeing lots of like you know can it
possibly make its money back articles
and now he's at a billion he's what 0.5
away
yeah I think 1.5 is his break even I'm
sure somebody will
uh and I was one of those people who was
like I think it'll do it but I think
it'll take a while
um because if following the same
patterns as the first avatar that that
was just in the top ten for like three
or four months
and so it it it
crossed that Mark but it took some time
to do I was wrong Back to the Island
guy from Long Island about his two kids
no bye Long Island
kids
okay I I have it do we want to see it
it's not
um I see it it's not pornographic
okay it's it's
really strange well let's throw it out
there let's see what AI thinks
there it is
I don't
I mean okay I mean all things considered
Mark's a little older and I'm a little
older did they say we're old
you know and like painted by the AI that
painted the good times poster
[Laughter]
oh my God you're right put it back up
your arms should be like this
like I look like Jim Brown in that third
one with the full why do I have a
baseball hat on
in the second panel Kevin your hat is
like a Sherlock Holmes hat it's front
and backward
I'm so in love that I double brimmed uh
going both ways for you and the 14 I
guess is for how many years we've been
in love
thank you internet yes thank you we're
not getting hassled we're not getting
hustled we're keeping our heads above
water make it a wave if we can
temporary layoff Good Times easy credit
ripoff Good Times uh there's something
about a child line
am I allowed to sing good times anymore
can you not is it we should just stop
right now are there bylaws that I
haven't seen the latest update too also
it's like coming in on the course of
course is generally sung like a gospel
choir and even that that feels
it was a very culturally appropriating
on my behalf oh I'll do that part hold
on let's be fair you did call me what a
middle-aged heavyset black man or
something I did I did oh
part of the club welcome aboard
uh all right all right so wait so Avatar
does the billion and it that means if it
didn't how many days 14. there's no way
don't break even now the big question of
is will it be profitable and of course
if they're gonna get to 2 billion at
least looks like
um and at that point I guess that green
you know not like he needs to wait for a
green light but I'm sure that makes him
feel better about the other one
yeah and you know it's it's one of those
things where it's still a movie that
will be in theaters for a long time like
it's not really going anywhere there's
no real competition for it until
February where I think you get Ant-Man
quantumania
um and so that's a clear month and a
half almost I've just open Open Seas
nothing's going to compete with it I
mean there's other stuff coming out
clearly but
nothing on that scale
true
didn't they also didn't he also say that
he shot the third and the fourth one
like are already in the can like he shot
all of them at the same time so who
really knows what the budget is
like he he was like I don't want my
movie to be like The Stranger Things
phenomenon where they age
so like our is Avatar three and four
already
like the motion capture already done on
those it doesn't I believe it is so like
the next ones might be cheaper because
the actors have already been like just
the budget
go in I mean the second one that way
says that most of three is shot I mean
it's not like bow Trek I don't know that
bow check worked on it but they're all
coming through now uh Rob Johnson says
three has done four shot and post and
has some filming complete
you know what I found out that I didn't
[ __ ] know about Avatar this week the
little if you've if you've seen it we're
not spoiling it the little girl who
magic Blue Cat who could like you know
[ __ ] Jedi that [ __ ] yeah Sigourney
Weaver I had no idea that was 20 Weaver
that was pretty astounding I was pretty
astounded by that I was like oh my God I
like that's great and then when I
thought about it I was like she did kind
of look like her and so they just and
then I saw online the behind the scenes
and they were shooting her and then
turning her into a teenage girl blue cat
oh it was yeah he is a mad genius man
yeah I love that behind the scenes stuff
for being mad he seems angry all the
time yeah like here's a collection of
Sully kids here's kid one here's kid two
and they're they're both like teenagers
or young adults and then here's kid
three and he was a 60 year old woman
gallivanting on leaves like
it's a little a little weird but hey
Sigourney Weaver one of our finest
actresses No Deal McCutchen in chat says
glue don't you
don't even know what that means but
talking about the cats
close
um it is uh yeah that was that was nuts
man like who
you're just setting yourself up for like
all sorts of complications when you're
like we're gonna let Sigourney play the
play the 12 year old or whatever the
teenage girl but like what in astounding
feat it was this is kind of cool yeah so
different from like the Irishman when
like young De Niro is being still played
by old De Niro and like those guys don't
move downstairs the way they used to
foreign
says 2 billion is the break even for all
of two and most of three and a small
part of four
that's creative Hollywood financials if
financials and accounting is always so
creative
this is incredibly creative and also
like this is an animated movie they're
all animated movies in that the live
action production is the Least
Complicated part of these movies most of
it's shown on a volume most of it's shot
and it doesn't take a ton of time to
shoot on the volume because you're not
doing camera setups you're not doing
lighting you're just capturing
performance but everything that happens
when you're creating Blue kittens and a
fake Blue kitten world is what takes
time and money and so just having it in
the can doesn't actually really scratch
the surface of how much these things
cost no not at all man uh indentured
Explorer and chat said just proves her
range though about Sigourney Weaver's
performance it did because in the piece
I saw she like studied to get her voice
she trained to get her voice like I
thought like oh they put her through a
processor they didn't that's her doing a
teenager's voice and she like practiced
and [ __ ] like that and like worked on
her vocals vocalizations so that she
could do the voice I thought that was
kind of but in in denture Explorer point
out something I think is absolutely true
um
staying relevant is awesome more so for
her it's CR like Sigourney Weaver has
not gone away since the 70s man in every
decade she has been a movie star who's
done something some iconic work
she says she don't get enough credit man
I mean you know every once in a while I
remember Jennifer Lawrence like was like
Hey man [ __ ] I'm the first Action
Hero yeah
but uh and then you know everyone's like
Ripley bro Ripley
um it's true and also Foxy Brown sis
Courtney Weaver's got something iconic
going on good for her she does yeah I
remember like you got Galaxy Quest she
got like
Gorillas in the Mist everyone loves that
working girl who doesn't love a good
working girl bro she's she's just
[ __ ] astounding and working girl
she's so passive aggressive wonderful
ice queen you just made me want to watch
that and I got a movie theater
don't dare me yeah
Harrison Ford has a wonderful moment
where he's like getting changed like in
his Mike Nichols movie right and so he's
on the phone in the foreground getting
changed he's got glass office walls
behind him and as he's taken off his
shirt like the other the women in the
office are gathering and like looking at
him he doesn't realize it then finally
he sees them and he like poses for him
he goes like
very adorable Harrison Ford moment
um the uh the um one other news item yes
uh a good friend of uh the show of pop
culture
of uh every child's imagination and
every Marvel fan would have turned a
hundred
this week if Stanley was still with his
kids it would have been his 100th
birthday the Centennial Sensational
Centennial
for the great uh late great Stanley
um so pour one out
I'm in a comic book store so I'm not
going to pour one out on these Comics
that makes no [ __ ] sense but what's
this look at this
did he
ah
stand with the Batmobile it's like when
you get one of those off-brand Superman
figures and it says Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and you buy it in the store
these two things generally don't go
together yeah man good old stand
um
it was uh a privilege and an honor to
have uh even met the guy let alone to
have spent real time with them and uh
you know it's just weird to know living
history like that like
a lot of people know him from like the
movies and [ __ ] and at the end of the
day I'm like I knew that guy like
actually very well uh so happy uh
birthday damn belated birthday
or what do you call a birthday when the
person that's still a birthday right
even if they're dead still the day they
were born it still is and keep on going
we're not aging anymore but he's ageless
anyway
I remember when I told this story before
but when they gave he came to us on
Mallrats Jim Jacks was like he's 75 he
could go at any minute so be careful
with him he lived for like another 22
years or whatever the [ __ ] and he
outlived poor Jim Jacks For Heaven's
Sake so you couldn't stop Stanley oh
somebody did time eventually
he was relentless man he is the perfect
commercial for living in California
really was man he's an East coaster once
California and he stayed younger than
hell even when he was 96 years old he
didn't look 96 years old
that's that California living kids
indeed or paid for by the great state of
California
we found California for sponsoring this
podcast just like native
um all right we're done with the news
man done with the news
um I I have compiled a list that I'm
calling the [ __ ] that I loved in 2022
list it has both movies and TV on it it
is in no way comprehensive because there
there is stuff that I just haven't seen
yet
um but here's the stuff that I can
confidently stand behind and say I love
the [ __ ] out of this
um I have five honorable mentions and
ten things on the list where do you want
to start
number one
absolutely no let's let's start we'll
build we'll build up to anticipation uh
your list I'll let you go where you want
to go all right let's do some honorable
mentions I think there's a couple of
these that you will appreciate and a
couple of these that you have not seen
at all but
uh first honorable mention Reacher
oh
oh
I just I is the store closed anybody
here
just you guys I come to watching that
[ __ ] show I'm gonna make sure no kids
were in here it is a comic book stuff oh
my God I remember when Mark was like you
should watch feature and I'm like what
and it was honestly the greatest gift
that anyone's giving me shy of Jennifer
giving me Harley
it's Mark giving you Richard I'm not
even talking about clerks giving me a
career [ __ ] all that noise look what I
did with it nothing uh Mark giving me
Reacher gave me so much happiness I I
I had such a great time watching it and
then I read some story recently about
the head of Amazon saw season two and
he's like it's incredible it's like
Richard goes to New York or some said
[ __ ] like Muppets
oh I loved Reacher man what's that
dude's name Alan Alan richson oh cast
him is everything there's your [ __ ]
next Batman Jesus Christ but why bother
he'd be redone to them and play Batman
and to put a mask on and be silly
because he's kicking ass and [ __ ]
killing people and and [ __ ] meeting
Justice with his bare [ __ ] hands
without wearing a mask so I love Reacher
love it you say something about it I
don't know what more there is to say
about it Beyond it's you know it's it's
the Punisher meets Batman show that
you've always kind of wanted
um I do love that every time he goes
into this Giant mountain of a man can
find clothes off the rack like I'm gonna
go into the thrift store and buy the
biggest pair of jeans you have
um but no it's just it's fun it's
exploitation it's it's all the things
you kind of want
um popcorn brutal popcorn entertainment
to be
and just well made man and those like
I'm
it actually made me go like maybe I want
to read those books
it's like I mean I won't but maybe I
won't I won't but in another world
if I was a dude who'd lied on a beach uh
maybe alas no uh number two on the
honorable mentions list Lord of the
Rings rings of power
you watched it I watched all of it
and you legit liked it I legit liked it
um I had one slot on this list for like
shiny fantasy thing and uh and I I had
more fun watching this than I did House
of the Dragon
um and it's it's I I can't even say that
it's like amazing but I think that it
just does the things that I kind of
wanted it to do
um we'll we'll go back to that but we'll
just tag up on reach your sinful hands
and chat had a pitch for a Reacher
sequel
uh where he travels the globe and it's
called Reacher around the world
not bad not bad at all
so that Rings thing obviously uh you
know we saw clerks too you know my
feelings on those Rings boo uh I didn't
I didn't dive in at all but you were
satisfied as a long time Tolkien uh fan
as a as your as your as your token token
negro
um I am indeed
laughs I uh I I was I'm a fan of the
movies I love the books
um and this just did the thing I wanted
to do which was bring me back into that
World
um and then show me the expanse of it
and take me on an adventure and show me
new characters and old characters and
and yeah I mean it's again not great
there's one great reveal in it that I
actually really really loved but it's
like
the rest of it just enough to be an
honorable mention but uh but I did have
more fun watching it than I did the
other one you know what quit your day
job because they love you as a comedy
writer they loved your tokian joke
go the [ __ ] home you did it
um number three on my album mentions
list was uh Black Panther wakanda
forever
um I think for all of the reasons that
we've talked about in the past uh on
this podcast I think it's when it is
engaging with grief
when it's engaging with the loss of both
t'challa and and Chadwick I think it's
remarkable I think it's it's so deeply
felt and it's so deeply earned
um I think no more
um as played by Terra Huerta is
fantastic I think he's a great
antagonist I don't think he's a villain
but I think he's a good antagonist
I just think that that what kept it from
being on my top 10 list was there was
just parts of the movie that did not
engage me emotionally really I think
that there's the Riri Williams stuff
didn't quite work for me
um I saw a commercial a ReRe only Iron
Heart commercial when I was in Target
really yeah like a whole little
Adventure you know it was a commercial
but ultimately I was like oh wow
actor looks familiar and it was it was
not
um did you also see in the news this
week that like uh there was a site that
purported to have an early look at
Mephisto
um you know uh Borat playing
and they're saying that Mephisto is
going to be an iron heart
I mean there's all an art show that's
coming I'm saying like that but did you
ever it was weird characters together
Mephisto and ironheart not at all
wouldn't would never have picked that
out of it so it's because of Any Marvel
thing that had mephisto's debut would
you have ever in a million years been
like oh yeah ironheart yeah that's
that's odd but uh but yeah like that is
the first time in a in a Black Panther
movie
that it felt like it had to tee up a
thing for another Marvel thing
you know like every the first Black
Panther movie was this perfect on its
own Island that did not have to really
connect with the rest of the MCU it did
gently if you needed it to but it was
about Black Panther it was about
t'challa was about that world at wakanda
and the Riri Williams of it all just did
feel very much like the big hand of
Marvel saying you have to set this
character up so we know who she is for
the TV show that's coming next year
um less than she's an integral part of
this drama that's unfolding
um and so it just it kind of bucked me
and rubbed me a bit the wrong way
um and as as as good as the design and
some of the effects were it's hard to
have an underwater Kingdom look as
remarkable as avatars Did It suffers for
comparison
um to the way of water which is the next
thing on my honorable mentions list is
Avatar the way of War
um of a lot of people pointing out in
chat Mephisto is there because the
villain is the hood
in ironheart right okay uh not only were
they saying that some people like you're
in a comic book store go [ __ ] read a
comic book you jerk I'm like all right
fair enough simmer down I guess I'll
read them all
uh don't forget kids not only I'm in a
comic book store but on January 4th
which is in a few short days oh quick
stops number three and masquerade number
four drops man a double dose from Secret
Stash plus
um back to you look at this this [ __ ]
wall flatting and covered up pillow
pants [ __ ] troll look at him look at
how adorable that is
okay so avatars next on your list
Avatar's next on the list
um I think it's it's a remarkable
achievement in making [ __ ] look amazing
um I think the the story is much like in
the first one a little bit shallow
um it's it's in the shallow end of the
pool but you know when James Karen does
the things that James Cameron is great
at which is staging action which is
Conjuring The Impossible which is
ratcheting tension it's still pretty
phenomenal
um it is too long
um you know and I think we when we
talked about the movie we talked about
hey you could probably pull a good 40
minutes out of this movie and not really
suffer for its loss
and after seeing it twice I do believe
that to be true
um but it's still I mean if you see that
movie in IMAX 3D it is it is a
remarkable sit
um in the movies and so I think it earns
its place in an honorable mention
I'm co-sign it like you know it's it's
an achievement like you can't
even if you're like come on man this is
Pocahontas or Fern Gully with Smurfs uh
that's what Josh Roush says all the time
um it's you know like this this guy
literally forced the medium to grow
again because he wanted to see his blue
cats get wet so
it's like you know there will be some
cool effects in some movie that you care
deeply about down the road because then
Cameron you know laid the track right
with Avatar way of water so you know and
well it was it was like they could have
chopped a bunch out but
vastly entertaining movie indeed
it was an entertaining movie it was the
movie was vast there was so much a lot
of movies and he's clearly an absolute
[ __ ] genius but uh yeah that
definitely deserves to be on the list uh
and my number five honorable mention is
the woman King did we talk about the
women King at all a little bit but you
were a big fan
um I was a big fan I was a big fan I
think I might have it might have been on
a black man beyond while you were still
on tour that I mentioned having to go
see it or having gone seen it not having
to go see it
um but I quite liked it I did I mean I
think the the direction by Gina Prince
blythwood is is Flawless
um she is still operating at the top of
her game I think Violet Davis is doing
[ __ ] Viola Davis [ __ ] which means
she's one of the best actresses working
and I think the story while a a rewrite
of the historical accuracy of who those
know warriors were the egoje in uh in in
that particular region of Africa I think
it's still it it follows enough of the
Beats I mean it's it follows a kind of
bravehearty feel and it just happens to
be set with a bunch of black women
um and so I think that that the
performances are great the action is
great the the location is interesting
um and it's a story it's a story that
feels familiar about people you've never
seen in a story like this
um so I dug it I dug it worth a watch if
you haven't seen it
okay I haven't seen it yet so I'll give
it his watch
um and that is the end of my honorable
mentions list the honorable mentions so
what's next next is number 10 on the
list of [ __ ] that I love top ten here
you go kids there's 10 things that Mr
Mark Bernard loved in 2022. indeed that
is his wife number two is his children
and then eight things and then and then
three was like podcasting and then
number four was you know cheeseburgers
and then six things
um now number 10 is Star Trek strange
new worlds
um which If You're a Star Trek fan
and by Star Trek fan I mean a classic
kind of OG people in a spaceship jetting
from planet to planet solving a dilemma
of the week
um while being Upright Citizens of the
Federation then this is the Star Trek
that you've been waiting for because
while I do like Discovery while I do
like Picard for obvious reasons
um this is this is classic Star Trek uh
featuring The Classic Star Trek Captain
of Captain Pike
um you know and you get Uhura and you
get Spock and I'm sure that Scotty's
going to show up at some point there's
going to be a bones like they're
basically giving you the prequel to The
Classic Star Trek show from the 60s and
it just feels fun and it feels light and
everybody's having a good time and more
to the point it feels like Star Trek and
so I'm uh I was pleasantly surprised
because I thought that I was a little
bit
um weary of Star Trek
um having been both a viewer for 40
years and a enlistee of Starfleet for
one
um but uh but I think it's great
nice number ten there it is kids
number 10 there it is Mark's still there
for it man boldly going where
many
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh number nine on the list Peacemaker
Peacemaker was of this year's show it's
crazy it feels so long though God the
opening like [ __ ] credits alone made
that thing a thing of Joy but one of my
favorite things I saw I guess in 2022
was
um John Cena and his [ __ ] underwear
dancing around to House of Payne this is
like an incredibly sad
Montage of his childhood and stuff
showing you like where he came from was
after I saw that I texted Mr Gunn was
like [ __ ] you're one of the best of us
man if not the best like that's some
beautiful [ __ ] right there yeah I mean I
think that it is that was just a
touching moment the rest of it is just
like fun and funny and this is
everything you always wanted like
[ __ ] I was reading comics as a kid
like oh wouldn't it be great if they
cursed and now they do and now they do
you know and it was also you know the
thing that surprised me although I'm not
sure if I should have been surprised or
not but how directly it ran at sort of
nationalism and white supremacy and and
all of that
um did not expect it in in Peacemaker
um but it 100 made sense as to who made
that person the way he is how does he
grow up to be The Peacemaker what are
the what are the building blocks to that
particular puzzle and once you meet his
dad you kind to begin to understand it
um and it I I would have put the boys on
this list as well I was trying to keep
this to new [ __ ] that I saw this year
but it was a one-two punch with the boys
season three in terms of dealing very
much with the now
in a way that uh that was insightful and
unsparing
um about just talking openly and
honestly I think about the world we
currently live in
so yes Peacemaker
can't wait for more but yeah James did
something special with that shot yeah
the special that DC was like come
[ __ ] run everyone because here's the
keys yeah do more of that but like you
know with Superman and [ __ ]
um number eight top gun Maverick
um which I don't remember if you saw or
if you saw you're like that's fine
I did see it
and you know I was like it's well made
and stuff but you know I and he was you
know Tom Cruise he cruised
ultimately like I was never a Big Top
Gun guy when I was a kid I saw it once I
I only have ever seen Top Gun drunk Top
Gun two once and that's it so I I get it
like I'm not like why this [ __ ] like
I totally get it but it's just not I was
never really invested in Maverick and
stuff so like you know I'm happy for Tom
Cruise seem to be having a good time and
made a lot of money for Paramount like
which offset whatever happened with
uh Babylon
but uh yeah and again I'm not [ __ ]
on it I'm just not a
Big Top Gun guy but yeah you like quite
a bit I did like it quite a bit I mean
it's it is Tom Cruise doing that which
only at this point a handful of people
can do which is just be a [ __ ] movie
star
um and it also does the thing that that
I think people are beginning to lean
deeper into which is
exploiting the baggage and the
connection that we have with
vintage Legacy Media
which is there's Nostalgia for Top Gun
there's there's a real people have I'm
not gonna say form their identities
around it but it was a part of their
childhood and so to re-engage with it
and to advance it and to find new
wrinkles in it while delivering you know
just a very very expertly done action
movie
um yeah I just I very much dug it it was
one of my favorite times in the theater
going like holy [ __ ] did they just make
a Top Gun movie that I cared about like
a lot huh
didn't expect that to happen
but it did you need to be fair he did
he'd been here about it for a while and
they were smart to hold it for as long
as they did yeah they were rewarded man
a lot of people were like pulling you
know the switch and going like I'll put
it on streaming do this do this and and
Dave Paramount and Tom Cruise were like
no we're gonna wait until the movie
theater is better again and then release
it and they knew what they had imagine
what it would have made pre-pandemic
yeah
yeah I mean it's it's almost hard to say
because it was greeted I think a bit as
like the returning champion of the this
was the reward for having set through a
pandemic for two and a half years there
was an embracing of it as like water in
the desert
where it might not have quite met with
that if it was just business as usual I
it's hard to tell but either way Bravo
everybody who made a top gun Maverick
uh Russell cook and chat said I hated
Top Gun one but Top Gun 2 [ __ ] rips
that's you can't ask for a better review
than that no I mean especially if you
like Star Wars yeah legit like I didn't
I didn't care for the first one but I
[ __ ] love this thing yeah
um edit numbers in at number seven is
prey
the sequel oh that was prequel
to uh to Predator
um which I I was lucky enough to see on
the big screen we were lucky enough to
be invited to the premiere of it and I
just found it phenomenal like the
direction was incredibly smart
incredibly tight the lead Amber mid
Thunder is terrific and just a
recontextualization of the predator and
Mythos
um
in in a in a sort of newly Colonial
Place
um set in and amongst the the indigenous
Americans I just thought it was great
and you also had a [ __ ] predator in
it um doing cool ass predatorship
um
you know it is it was very much a good
object lesson of yeah you can actually
be kind of respectful and diverse and
tell a story with empathy and have it be
good and have it be [ __ ] awesome and
have it kick ass
um without the you know go woke go broke
argument which never actually holds
um
you're getting a lot of love and chat
for prey
so good so far but everyone's cosine in
your list nobody's fighting your list at
all but pray a lot of people like oh
crazy on my list as well
excellent ooh Batman's here hey bamf man
you raced in just like Pietro
is he saying a thing
you gotta unmute yourself
JC what are you doing
[ __ ] we brought the show to a
screeching [ __ ] Hall is your mom
Mike's dead
no okay well bye
foreign
all right in at number six Glass Onion
a Knives Out mystery you've seen it I've
seen it I saw it both in the theater I
went I went to the theater on my
birthday to go see Glass Onion on a big
screen and then again on Netflix
um and you know much like the first
knives out which you know I don't I
don't I've read that Ryan Johnson does
not like to have to call them Knives Out
Mysteries because it's it should be it
should be like a Benoit Blanc mystery
like that's the connective tissue it's
not a sequel to knives out as much as
it's just a brand new thing
knives out but he cops to the fact that
that's how you Market it yes he's like I
wish we didn't have to do that but I get
that we did and so I understand it I
just wish
um but it's it's pretty terrific
what's going on
I don't know I don't want to get too
smoky in here lines I got a lot of comic
books in here
[Laughter]
that would be the best way to end 2022
it's just standing in his comic book
store with the sprinklers going off
that
that's a wrap folks
but yes Glass Onion
um you know it's a it's a character
Ensemble who done it murder mystery much
like the first one was
um new characters a bunch of them you
know almost all of them
um new mystery clearly a new antagonist
who's wonderful
um Ryan Johnson has said that his miles
Braun is not a direct riff
on Elon Musk even though he 100 feels
like a direct Riff on Elon Musk
um basically the the penetrating the
veil of hyper-rich tech billionaires who
pretend to be brilliant
um even though
most of the time they're not
um it uh and it's just fun and smart and
it all holds having seen it twice just
and you know when you see it the second
time you begin to see all of the sutures
and all of the ways in which it's
connected and holds and I think it's
wonderful and Ryan Johnson remains a
fantastic director and like he just he
understands how to do this [ __ ] he
understands at a stage of scene he
understands kind of make it so that six
people standing in the screen at once
all have different values and shades and
Hues and levels of importance and
I don't know man I just I enjoyed the
hell out of it
um good for him I haven't seen it yet
but I've not met a person that doesn't
like it yeah I'm sure I'll like it as
well I mean New Year's Day sitting in
the movie theater and have a marathon
watch a bunch of stuff that oh I haven't
seen that should be on the top of the
list that sounds dreamy I mean why else
buy a movie theater if you can't [ __ ]
Citizen Kane your way into that [ __ ] and
she'd be like I'm gonna stay here all
day Bring Me Bon Bons
um you know
I I don't eat bonbons kind of [ __ ]
horrible stereotype you laying on me
do I look like a bonbon person
I'm not a bonbon boy to you whatever
funny to you what I look French to you
instead of eating bon bons
uh in at number five as we crack the top
half of the list
uh is Miss Marvel
yeah what a wonderful show that was yeah
like I I hear it as well wow I had zero
expectations for it
um I expected I expected my Marvel thing
this year to have been either black
panther or Doctor Strange too and black
panther sort of made the cut Doctor
Strange 2 did not but Miss Marvel was
the one that just surprised the [ __ ] out
of me at almost every turn
um Iman villani is a discovery as as
Kamala Khan
um and the the specificity of that world
of the sort of Pakistani immigrant life
living in New Jersey
um it's it's just so wonderfully
specific that it begins to open up the
entire sort of emotional canvas of who
is this young lady what does she want
what are her struggles what are her
dreams how are her specific dreams just
like everybody else's you know what's
the history of her family and her people
and to take an entire episode and teach
me about partition like yeah educate me
while you're at in entertaining me I'll
take them both
um and I thought that it resolved in a
fantastically intimate way it did not
need to get bigger because bigger was
not what this show is asking for and so
when it does become just a like we're
gonna have this kind of conflict final
Conflict in a high school where we kind
of started it all
um just in and amongst our core crew
um I appreciated it
um it was also just insanely well shot
and produced remember how fun it was
yeah just visually to look at yeah like
every text message was somehow
incorporated into the background
animation in some way and just the
storytelling was incredibly Vivid yeah
yeah I had thought those are the kids
that were supposed to or did make
Batgirl right so they got they got Ms
Marvel showed off their chops man
um the wonderful show for all the
reasons Mark said plus just so visually
engaging I felt one of the best looking
of the Marvel shows in terms of
presentation it had a voice like yeah
out of style
very much so so yeah Ms Marvel is in at
number five
um number four was Interview with a
Vampire
which I did not expect to like
um I've I've read the book I read the
book when I was in high school when I
think everybody if you're going to
discover Anne Rice you discover Anne
Rice when you're in high school
um I've seen the movie which you know
has its lures to be sure Tom Cruise you
know favorite of this list
um gives a phenomenal performance as
Lestat
um as the vampire Lester and so when I
heard that AMC was doing a series of
interview November I was like all right
well whatever I'll watch one episode
um and what ended up happening was it it
it is a sequel that or a reboot that
does not exonerate the original it
incorporates the events of the movie
um it retells them from a different
perspective
and it recasts the entire tenor of the
story by making
um
Louis
um
a gay black man in sort of late 19th
early 20th century New Orleans which
suddenly it becomes a very different
story suddenly becomes a story about
race and class and gender and power and
privilege and Prestige and what happens
when you give somebody who has none of
that stuff the power of a vampire you
know and and that I found incredibly
rich
just ground to start to till and the
places that they went with it
um I just found intoxicating every
episode I thought it was it was
phenomenal
and that's coming from an old school fan
yeah like I I you know I I never quite
understood what Brad Pitt's Louis was
always whiny about like oh yeah so
you're a rich white dude who's upset
that the plantations I guess aren't
making as much money as they used to
make oh no whereas now it's oh you're a
black dude whose family has money but
you want you want to elevate your status
in life you want to elevate your class
but all of the the power structures all
of the systems in New Orleans at the
time were not arrayed in your favor and
so how do you jump that boat how do you
how do you how do you break that
particular ceiling well
you become a vampire but then it still
doesn't [ __ ] work like there's
something kind of lovely about the
prison that that character still finds
himself in even with immortality
um I I just thought it was incredibly
deep and Incredibly Rich
where do they find it where is it who's
there uh it was on AMC
um and so if you have the AMC plus you
can probably
um watch it right now I'm not sure if
it's on on demand but uh AMC spent
through the nose for the Anne Rice
catalog and uh and if this is how
they're doing it then I'm on board for
more they have the Mayfair witches which
I think is another
um Anne Rice series coming in January
but I mean there's a lot of vampire
Mythos that they have to to go through
and so if this is just season one then
bully for them and Bully for me what
number is this on your list this was
number four that's rather High man
that's a high and that's a late Comer
right you only that was like October
yeah
that was that was a Halloween that was a
Halloween Jammy Jam
all right all right
uh all right top three let's let's
recount let's recap the bottom seven
before we go to the top three an
Entertainer you are [ __ ] you
understand Mr Larry Kathy those who came
in late here comes the zaddy's got a
recap for you
40. right now
uh in at number 10 was Star Trek strange
new worlds number nine Peacemaker number
eight top gun Maverick number seven prey
number six Glass Onion a knives at
mystery number five Miss Marvel and
number four Interview with a Vampire
in at number three the shortest title on
the list may be the longest movie on the
list
[Music]
it was a discovery that just I kind of
stumbled upon I heard whisperings on the
internets about this movie
um out of India that was this amazing
kind of martial arts Kung Fu action
um romance musical called RR
what the 3r stand for seem to be up for
some debate rise rage Revolt perhaps
unclear
um but it is the most insane film I've
seen in a long time it is incredibly
Earnest
um it is nothing but a platonic Love
Story between these two guys on opposite
sides of the British occupation in India
um
one guy plays an Indian who's working
for the Brits another guy plays a a an
Avenger of the forest who's come to find
a kidnapped girl in the in the British
stronghold in uh and I and I cannot
remember what city that this is in in
India
um but there's like
Tiger fights there's Musical dance
numbers there's one man versus a hundred
men fight scenes there's weaponized
Jungle Cats there's
everything you could possibly imagine in
a movie is in this movie
um I've
I I cannot I can't compare to anything
else on this list even the number two
movie which is also almost every movie
you've ever seen at once but
um there's just something so so Earnest
about it it deeply believes in
everything that it's putting on the
screen there's no irony there's no
looking sideways at it it is just these
two men are in love and then they're on
opposite sides of it love and then they
will cross the boundaries of space and
time to reconnect with each other and
defeat the evil British occupiers
because
all of the reasons so yes if you have
not seen RR
[ __ ] crr
long it's like three and a half hours
long I will see it but [ __ ] throwing
a cat at another person
intrigues me I don't like that sort of
thing but it's a movie
well I here's a [ __ ] scene here's a
guy trying to break into the big British
stronghold and he's on his truck and
he's on the roof of the truck and he
bursts through one gate he burst through
another gate and a bunch of dudes are
sitting there with the machine guns
aiming at the truck is going and the
truck does a [ __ ] skid and out of the
back of the truck it happened to be an
exotic animals [ __ ] conveyance and so
all these gates open and then there's
here's a [ __ ] water buffalo here's a
tiger here's a crane here's this all
jumping out of the back of this [ __ ]
truck to take on anybody that's in his
way it's
crazy pants wonderful
I'm done I'm gonna check it out is on
you saw it on Netflix it's on Netflix
um I think there's a there's a dubbed
version there's a subtitled version you
know I see it however you can see it
it's terrific
um so that was number three RR number
two I might have tipped at when I was
talking about number three
um everything everywhere all at once
wonderful movie oh my God like actually
she might win the Academy Award this
year I think that if if anybody has you
know a Goodwill and B the great
Narrative of I have been one of the
world's finest actresses for some 40
years and only now you are seeing
everything that I can do because this
was the first movie that let me do
everything that I can do
um I think kihu Kwan has a really good
shot because again The Narrative of I
was [ __ ] Short Round
no I was in The Goonies and then I
Disappeared for 40 years
um because I didn't think anybody gave a
[ __ ] about me and so here's my comeback
vehicle which again lets me do
everything I've ever been able to do
um and it's this incredibly heartfelt
story about finding yourself and
discovering who you are
um and having the people in your life
see you for who you are
um which also happens to have this crazy
multiversal story a ton of kung fu in
action
um deeply introspective scenes where you
know and everything bagel is the both
Center of and destroyer of the Universe
um it's it is everything and I I saw it
by myself in the theater and like wept
openly like two or three times because
it is also deeply emotional and
beautiful
um the Daniels are the filmmakers and
and this seemed to be the thing that
they'd somehow I desperately want to
know how they pitched this movie because
so much of his visual so much of his
conceptual it's almost like you just
have to have a leap of faith that we're
gonna be able to pull us off and they
did they did they did I think it's it's
the best movie I saw this year
which means that number one is not a
movie
number one is in fact a television show
it is the best TV show that I've seen
all year
it is Andor
oh my God Andor is number one for you
that was the thing this year and or is
number one for me and or and or would be
a fantastic TV show even if it wasn't
Star Wars even if it was just we are
telling you the story of a rebellion we
are telling you the story of the price
people pay we're telling you the story
of the mechanics of raising money we're
telling you the story of the people who
get caught up in the meat grinder of
gigantic despotic
um sort of bureaucracies but then when
you also make it about Star Wars when
you also make it about man mafma and
everything that she has to do as a
senator before she gets to be the
[ __ ] lady planning Death Star raids
you know if it gets to be about you know
all of the people who you would
eventually see like die in Rogue one
um introducing new characters you've
never seen before and may never see
again reconnecting with characters from
like clone wars and deepening them and
enriching them
um and casting it with some of the best
people who've ever done it I mean Diego
Luna is amazing [ __ ] the two scenes
you get Forest Whitaker are amazing
um Stellan Skarsgard is doing [ __ ]
career beating best work in this
um and it's Tony Gilroy who's written
some of the best movies in the last 40
years who knows how to [ __ ] tell his
story
and it rewards patience
you know it does not race out of the
gate you know I think that if there's a
knock on and or it's that it takes its
time
um but there's always something to
appreciate every scene has something new
every every interaction between two
characters is about something and it's
all leading somewhere
um and it's telling these these somewhat
I'm not going to say siled stories but
it's telling stories in triplicate where
it's the first three episodes are one
story the second three episodes are
another story the third three episodes
on another story
and they all keep adding up they all
keep compounding on each other and they
all keep telling you the story of what
it costs what does rebellion cost you
know it's easy for like Luke Skywalker
to hop in a [ __ ] X-Wing and Trust in
the force and blow it up but who paid
for the next Wing like who's that like
what what do people have to give and
what does a populist need to sacrifice
before they're willing to rise up and I
thought
to tell that in Star Wars
you know to tell that to use the
vestiges to use our our affinity for it
and then find something incredibly new
to say about it which nobody said
anything new about Star Wars in a very
long time
um and so yeah I just I loved every
minute of it I can't want to watch it
again
I messed with the mic because people
said I was too loud and then I broke
stuff uh but I'm back I'll also say
about Andor
is that uh in a world where Star Wars
television looks like television and or
for all 10 hours of it looked like a
movie
the insert shots the cinematography the
way that they did the sound on it where
the sound played a role in the
storytelling was stuff that you don't
see on TV I was so good
uh I will finally [ __ ] with it maybe
over the holiday
um here's what I will add to the list uh
Sandman
was [ __ ] phenomenal I absolutely
loved it I can't believe
not only did they stick The Landing but
you know they made [ __ ] Calliope in a
dream of a thousand cats like
happy for Neil because man he held on to
his baby forever and and everyone I
thought did a phenomenal [ __ ] job uh
the boys season what was it three that
we just had
[Music]
um that show cripke and Co continue to
[ __ ] absolutely
Crush that was such a fun watch each and
every week and they always showed us
something brand new
um let's see what else we got
um I really like the Guardians of the
Galaxy Christmas special as like a like
a saccharine 45 minute like I don't have
to watch Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer
Again movie
um I would put uh the fablemans on that
list
um I love the whole flick but I would
particularly put the last
five ten minutes of the fablemen the
whole John Ford sequence right up to the
last shot just if you're a fan of
filmmaking or you know you've ever
fancied yourself uh
uh Storyteller it's it's a story about a
Storyteller and uh and and it hits home
a lot of a lot of personal stuff in his
his personal life he put the most
uh confessional piece of art you'd think
that guy's ever made
out you know what I'm saying he's always
kind of hinted at
throughout most of his movies divorced
mothers have always been very prominent
and this movie kind of tells you why and
you know it's it take him taking us
through his
uh life through the you know the
characters and and watching him well you
get one of my favorite sequences
is
um in the beginning they take the kid to
see The Greatest Show on Earth and he
watches a train wreck in the movie
and you know it's haunts and scares and
you can't sleep and stuff and they asked
for a train set for Christmas and they
give him a train set and all he does is
want to track crash the trains over and
over
and his mom's trying to figure it out
and she's like he's he he's trying he
wants to control
like in that moment
never felt more seen by a [ __ ] movie
this year
with the exception of perhaps clerks
three
to feel very seen by but that [ __ ]
moment alone like her his mom figuring
out he's trying to control it like his
fear
that
that's
at the root I can't speak for every
artist but certainly at the root of this
artist is
you just want to control an
uncontrollable world
and you could do that with fake people
and fake situations and stuff like that
oh God that there's so many lines in
that movie that devastate there's
another line was it Tony Kushner wrote
it uh where you know he says you can't
just love something you have to take
care of it but hit his mom gets him a
camera
and says here now you can film the
trains crashing but you you only have to
do it once because you could do it with
the camera
and then there's this beautiful scene
where he takes his mom into the closet
sets up a projector and shows her the
movie he shot and it's him crashing the
trains over and over again from like a
thousand different angles and he's like
I had to crash it more than once and
she's just like it's beautiful I love it
and it's a setup I mean it's a beautiful
scene in and of itself but it's a setup
for scene a heartbreaking scene later on
in the movie when he brings his mom back
into the closet to show her movies
um it's not doesn't seem to be doing the
business I mean I was happy like we had
it at uh
smodcast Castle this week and you know
even though it's out on home video we
had a lot of people show up to see it
you know most of them were older folks
which like boy that's a sweet spot
but I absolutely adored that flick I
think about it all the time that's
Spielberg kid he may go someplace he's
seems to know
I uh I have I have to represent the chat
a lot of people calling out clerks three
uh on their list but I will say uh about
clerks three
is that when we went and saw it at the
premiere Jen who my gen who hadn't seen
clerks too
uh
loved the movie and it sat with her uh
in like a way about like talking about
aging and getting older and things like
that so it uh it meant something to
somebody who's like not
you know like Kevin Smith to her is like
the guy who likes shag artwork not like
the the clerks guy and so for her
yeah yeah the husband's friend uh the
guy who who's like dinner's gonna be at
six and I'm like I'll be in at eight uh
that guy is Kevin Smith guy
but she really really liked clerks and
had you know no reason to
um and no background on it so it it
works it really works I appreciate that
I uh I watched as the only movie that I
watched literally 75 times this year
on every stop of the convenience store
all 52 stops and thank you to everybody
who came out and sold us out time and
time again and stuff
um you know it held up for me I [ __ ]
adore that movie that's that may be my
favorite Kevin Smith movie
um I know you know Clark says everyone
the ones everyone's partial to but I God
I love clerks three and I love the lot
the people's reaction to it it's coming
out now it just popped down to
Blu-ray and DVD and uh you know the the
Best Buy had a [ __ ] 4K steelbook as
my first 4K release I believe definitely
my well not my first steelbook I think
they've done a Clarkson before my first
4K really
and so you know I've been getting more
people who've never seen the movie
before
uh reacting to it all throughout the
holidays like you know Twitter can be a
hellscape for some but since clerks 3
has come out it's been a lovely place
for me a lot of people like the movie
now I'm not saying that so A bunch of
people jump in and start [ __ ] in my
movies mouth and my mouth and [ __ ]
I'm not daring anybody to make it worse
um but it's been absolutely wonderful
ever since we put up the trailer for the
movie I was real scared when we put up
the trailer that people were gonna be
like [ __ ] you this again
[ __ ] get out of here and they they
went for it man it was said Thank you to
everybody who went to see it at a fathom
event screening or came to see it with
me on the convenience tour or watched it
you know on iTunes or Amazon or just
picked up a Blu-ray or a steel book
uh thank you uh for the support it was a
lovely
lovely uh year that tour was everything
that I hoped it would be I was dreaming
about that tour since the last tour and
then the pandemic happened and there was
a question if we'd ever be able to get
there we got there and every night it
was just
absolute [ __ ] Bliss they all made me
feel like a a good filmmaker so thank
you
um trying to think what else
um
yeah and and I would I would caution
anybody against believing that if it's
not on the list I didn't like it
um it is entirely possible that I didn't
see it
um there's a bunch of [ __ ] movies
especially in this last push as you know
people are releasing their Oscar things
I'm getting screeners and time is not my
friend and so like it is not a
commentary that a thing is on the list
there's some things that I like their
own like I like this Ant-Man quite a bit
um but it just you know in in whatever
Bizarro math was happening in my head
that day it just one thing beat it in
another thing didn't so
um oh yeah yeah it's not comprehensive
but it is complete what uh Hey kids in
chat what did we miss uh what did you
guys like this year that we didn't get
to I see a better call soon I'll shout
out there were a lot of
vlogging shout out
uh oh Victor Venn diagram said the black
man beyond episodes this year were so
much fun definitely want more of those
thank you a lot of people said the bear
yeah yeah there's a lot of love for the
bear
Yellow Jackets was that this year that
was this year the yellow jackets was
tight too man you know what I have not
seen any man with Jeff Bridges was also
really good too you know what I haven't
heard anybody asking for the Batman
which was also this year that happened
this year yeah
um some folks talk about Severance was
that this year
's one I haven't seen
the whale as well uh uh Guillermo del
Toros Pinocchio Moon Knight I was a big
fan of moon night [ __ ] loved it loved
every second of it
um couldn't believe we got a moon Night
series and what they did with it was
wonderful balancing the scales at the
end just so I I enjoyed it so [ __ ]
much remember summon the suit
um what else a lot of people of course
say stranger things I still haven't
[ __ ] with that
um but I hear great things
um
uh Cobra Kai season five
people love Pearl
right there
um reservation dogs which you've liked
as well the second season I mean I again
I was trying to make this the new [ __ ]
that I saw this year but if I had a
recurring favorites Reservoir Dogs is
among the best things that I've seen
this year the second season was
remarkable reservation dogs yeah did I
say Reservoir Dogs that you might have
Tom Tom Pam and Tommy that was a fun
[ __ ] watch as well that happened this
year
um
somebody said confess Fletch did you see
that yeah I did see it it's good right
yeah super fun yeah totally and not like
oh it [ __ ] replaces Chevy Chase or
whatever it's just another flavor but
but close to Gregory McDonald's stuff I
thought what was the director Greg Greg
matola did a wonderful job man uh
She-Hulk captains your paper girls that
was such a great watch although we'll
never get it again it looks like
um
uh let's see
emancipation says alien
Bixby anyway the Will Smith movie
um I I am never going to see that movie
[Music]
um our flag means death you were a fan
of that one I very much so
um
Elvis everyone's pointing out Elvis yeah
that's totally great that was so much
[ __ ] movie baz lorman was just like
take all the movies
um I keep seeing a lot of love for Tulsa
King what is that the Sylvester Stallone
thing yeah in Paramount plus the the
Taylor Sheridan
um series or a movie yeah series and
Sylvester Stallone's in it his first TV
show
and it's on Paramount plus that's the
guy that's the yellow stones and the
1883s and 1923s and
um yeah that guy [ __ ] they should make
him ahead of Paramount man I mean
they're paying him like he's the head of
Paramount
give him a pair of paramounts man uh
people love him what he's making
I feel like I'm I missed the boat
[Music]
yeah I saw his movies before he got into
the series yeah I love hell or high
water hell or high waters what a [ __ ]
great move that's such a great movie oh
one of my favorite last 10 years
um
okay
um
somebody said the Barbie trailer I mean
it was fine you know I mean nobody I
look forward to that movie in a big bad
way but the trailer was I mean it's a
teaser not even really trailer exactly
saying but I look forward to that
[ __ ] Barbie movie I said there's no
way it misses it looks so [ __ ] good
uh Barry somebody shouted out Barry had
a wonderful season this year terrifier
too man [ __ ] up good time with that we
had a screening at smog castle and it
was good [ __ ] times man it inspired
me made me want to make a very
inexpensive movie
um you know when a [ __ ] indie film
makes you wait an old ass Mindy
filmmaker go like ooh I would like to
make an indie film again that's that's
some good movie Megan right there
um
let's see what else we got in the chat
um
did you watch the weird the Al Yankovic
story I didn't I I don't have the rokin
channel I'm not sure where else I can
get it Barbarian JC killpack put out
Barbarian is [ __ ] wonderful Justin
Long
fantastic in the movie I would like to
watch that movie again it's so twisty
turny and [ __ ] um good good ass [ __ ]
flick man really great flip
[ __ ] with the kids if you ain't seen it
a lot of people giving love to the menu
uh which I ain't seen Roush you around
what'd you like this year
yeah we did that
talk about that
clerks three
that's how you do it Mark
I am not going to mention a movie that I
was in
[Laughter]
[Music]
it yeah man it was I this was a year
where I did a lot of uh
you know
um
I was out there making the thing and
then touring things so I didn't engage
as much with stuff but I I feel like I
did watch a bunch of things
like [ __ ] watched before I went out
on tour me and Jen like watched a [ __ ]
ton of TV because I got it done with my
edit on clerks three pretty
like early like you know we were
shooting in the summer of 2021
and then I was like by the New Year by
2022 top of the year I had my cut all
done and locked and [ __ ] like that so
there's a lot of TV watching and that
like I remember watching Reacher we had
such a [ __ ] blast man
and like Miss Marvel and Moon Knight
this is the year that Jen really started
[ __ ] hard with the Marvel
which was so nice for me
um I you know it Not only was it nice
that like oh she's engaged part of the
fun of watching anything that you love
with somebody you love who's never
watched that [ __ ] before
is yes the joy of sharing but also
specifically kids the joy of explaining
everything
favorite things I did all year was when
Jennifer was just like I don't get it
and I'd pause and be like well let me
explain see back in [ __ ] blah blah so
that was absolute [ __ ] Bliss
um
I guess that's it that's our list
everybody there it's a list you watch
Wednesday yet everybody loved ones I I'm
halfway through it and you know it's uh
it's it's giving me it's reminding me
why I liked Riverdale to begin with
um in that it's a bunch of kids at a
school where creep kooky [ __ ] [ __ ]
happens and there's a murder and
somebody's got to be solving it and so
it's Wednesday and so it's very y a but
it's why a from the disaffected youth
perspective
um which is also very Tim Burton
um I think that this is also one of the
you know the few TV things that Tim
Burton has done that he's directed every
episode so far and so it's got a very
burdening feel to it
um Jenna Ortega is phenomenal
um yeah I mean it's it's light but it's
fun
I dig it and I see why it's doing well
I got some love for wrong reasons up in
the chat a few people put wrong reasons
that was the Josh roush's movie with Liv
yes [ __ ] he said yeah from the back
um that we played at this mock Castle
film festival and then we played out in
Los Angeles and then it's coming
first first month of one of the the
first month of programming for January
for uh spot Castle January 25th to the
29th we're doing Rao Shaman a festival
of all this stuff
um folks I February 4th is going to be
clerks open all night where we show all
three clerks movies all night long and
give you a big Quick Stop bag full of
[ __ ] at the end of it
um because we moved to February 4th I
think
January leave January 21st to open kids
because I think something's going to
come together very quickly if you're a
fan of Mall Rats you might want to leave
that date open that's all I'm saying
um so yeah we're putting up the schedule
now for January and and in even more so
we got to build a bunch of artwork
um uh to start putting up sales well in
advance on on smodcast is
smartcastlecinemas.com which kids if you
go to smartcastlecinemas.com right now
you can buy tickets see me on New Year's
Eve a New Year's evening with Kevin
Smith man join the other
205 people who've already bought tickets
man uh pack into theater one the Don
Smith Memorial Theater at uh smart
Castle Cinemas in Atlanta Highlands New
Jersey and uh ring out 2022 with me and
bring in 2023. uh oh what good times
they'll be I'm gonna use my mouth on you
can you smuggle in booze
you don't even have to smuggle it BYOB
uh potent potables is going to be uh
giving out Libations there during the
show as well our good friends at
boatables so even though we don't have a
liquor license yet uh there will be
drinks uh served and uh you know kids
the guy who owns the theater the guy on
stage he smokes weed all the time so
what bring what you want somebody once
asked me like can I Vape in your theater
I was like
you could you could
you can have sex in my feet
that's that's I'm a film exhibitor I
want you there anyway shape or form just
buy a ticket buy some popcorn do
whatever you want in the theater bamf
this is where
Carol calls you and is like Kevin no
very true very true uh but there is an
outside you know go [ __ ] outside you
know have sex or smoke weed outside
all right is it time for questions I
believe it is time for the Q a all right
kids yeah
we're gonna end 2022 with questions
from you
no more ramming I mean it that's right
anybody want a peanut anybody want a
peanut
um
we've got some we've got some questions
I'm gonna push my stuff no cover New
Year's Eve for scum and villainy and
shampoo oh yeah hold on yeah my bad I
was blowing up about Jersey and [ __ ] but
JC is the proprietor of the scum and
villainy cantina which I'm sure is open
on New Year's Eve New Year's Eve what
are you guys doing no cover champagne
toast at midnight everybody every place
on New Year's these New Year's Eve has
it covered we don't uh and a free
champagne toast at midnight with blue
champagne blue like my shirt champagne
which is pretty wild and it's not just
us putting food coloring in it is
naturally blue
um and then Monday is my 42nd birthday
hey and so if I've learned
Girl You'll Be a Woman Soon well done if
I've learned anything in the last 10
years it's that uh your birthday is a
good time to monetize so I will be at
scum and Philly on Monday if anybody
wants to hang out uh you know what they
want to do they want to come in and buy
you a drink yeah so I'll be there uh at
some point
uh probably all evening if you want to
come come say hi
uh so that stuff Saturday and two
Saturday and Monday
tomorrow nice
and if it's not raining it's been
raining in La non-stop if it's not
raining we're going to open up the new
Hobbit patio oh it's happening so where
is it you gotta you got a photo or no I
don't have a photo yet but it's the
alleyway that used to be the trash
Alleyway Green Room has been converted
into a shire outdoor patio
uh so if you're if you want to hang out
where we used to step over human feces
and and do the pre-show
hopefully if it's not raining we'll we
will be I will be there on New Year's
Eve after 9 30.
kids whether whether you're shy or not
so shy
[ __ ] with The Hobbit land what are you
calling it
uh I think we're calling it The prancing
pony patio
nice is that code for something it's uh
if you're into token
[Laughter]
all right all right what what to ask of
the some questions three
uh
Wolverine Ortiz which I thought was
pretty clever Wolverine Ortiz
um
what group of fictional characters would
you like to party with or count down the
new year with and why and who are you
kissing if not your wives
oh cool all right so what part one is
what
who what group would you want to party
with on New Year's
a fictional band
group like band or [ __ ] like
fictional characters doesn't need to be
a band
Marvel Cinematic Universe Avengers from
Age of Ultron they look like they party
man
that seemed like a good [ __ ] time
that's my idea of New Year's Eve we all
sit around try to lift that guy's
[ __ ] Hammer that guy
Boris [ __ ] Hammer man like and we
drink you know [ __ ] booze that you
get
World War II survivors [ __ ] up as we
saw on that [ __ ] uh sand lead bit
um and then when [ __ ] gets slow murder
Bots all around
and everybody even even Maria Hills
pulling a Gun and shooting them in the
[ __ ] head so you're safe as a kid man
uh I choose to party with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Avengers number one
hanging out with [ __ ] Robert Downey
Jr well Tony Stark on New Year's
amazing man that'd be fantastic
um and then who would I want to kiss if
not my wife on New Year's fictional
character
well not Superman because that takes
away your memories
remember when he did that in the movie
Kiss Lois and she was like what's
happening in the world today
I guess in that [ __ ] dude
um oh I want to kiss
you have to be they don't have to be
like on the lips and tongue and [ __ ]
right
it's a new year to find your kiss it
could be a chaste kiss
like a kiss on a forehead yeah I'm
choosing my father I'm choosing my dad
that I used to kiss him on the forehead
good night and [ __ ] that'll bring him
back from the [ __ ] grape is he
present can I talk to him or he's like
what and I'm trying to kiss his foreign
[Laughter]
said gay to kiss my dad
on the forehead old account
and why is that negative
positive I go for you yeah
uh I am going to hang out New Year's Eve
in Las Vegas
with Danny Ocean's Eleven
I think that would be fun I think I
think George Clooney and Brad Pitt and
Matt Damon and [ __ ] Don Cheadle and
Bernie Mac and all those dudes that
would be a riot
um so yeah that's that's who I'm hanging
out with and if I'm not huh
uh manual D Manuel Diaz says your dad's
a fictional character I guess it had to
be a fictional character but I'll be
honest with you
the version of my dad that I talk about
all the time pretty much is a fictional
he's recalled through the prism of
memory and sentimentality so trust me
he's way more verbal than the stories I
tell than he ever was in real life
original Silent Bob so anyway back to
you mark who's your yes and if I have to
kiss a fictional character on the lips
who is not my wife
um it is very specifically Linda
Carter's Wonder Woman
what
what a deep cut what's that old about
because it's [ __ ] Linda Carter man I
mean look no
argument a stunning uh woman at any age
but but I had no idea you had a Linda
Carter thing uh I mean I have a I was a
boy when I first saw the Wonder Woman
and then I was a man when the Wonder
Woman ended
like what you doing why she keep
spinning like that why do I feel funny
well my pants getting tight
um wow what a great
man
why not if I if I gotta shoot the moon
then shoot it with a lady who can lasso
the Moon
um
I you know
I mean you can kiss your dad I mean
that's also fine
thanks thanks
for co-signing it late after you're like
Linda Carter
it's Wonder Woman herself yes not Linda
Carter she's a real lady
um
what about Steve Trevor
[ __ ] that dude you can pick some fake
lady to kiss a [ __ ] war hero you
monster
let him get his own Dame
uh there's your answers kids what about
you Banff man who you partying with I
feel like I should say the wookies from
Star Wars
[Music]
I feel like I should say the wookies
from the Star Wars holiday special but
for some reason the Scooby-Doo gang
seems like a fun
you get like a little party and a little
Adventure
all right
um and I think I would want just a peck
like at the smallest Peck from Rogue
that's my New Year's Eve kiss
yeah
just to like remember when uh when in
the movie when Iceman kissed her and
then she breathes out and is they're
like whoa it just seems fun
if I'm gonna kiss a fictional person
I could probably come home and be like
look
what I just wanted to see what it was
like it wasn't a real kit like I could
get away with it
you know cheated on you know who we
should all kiss Jeff
yes
oh
all right next question this uh the old
man himself I'm doing
um I'm doing this question from Tyler
hall because he's asked this question
every single show for like the last year
and a half and I've never picked his
question so I'm giving him he's about to
get a Christmas wish
third Act of a Dickens thing and and
also I won't have to get this in chat
for all of 2023 which is this is why
it's this is like oh Henry's The Gift of
the Magi we're my [ __ ] favorite
sequel revenge of the Magi
remember that story with magic came back
and [ __ ] and then at the last minute
they changed the title return of the
Magi because magi's can't have Revenge
whatever
so go ahead Tyler Hall wants to know
what the verse movie
team up
slash villain is and the the the kind of
train of thought was like Paddington
versus Pooh versus Yogi Bear
so who would be your like ultimate kind
of
team up in that in that way
bear fight well or it could be raccoon
fight or I think things that kind of
line up right
like mixed IP that kind of lives in the
same world so like a dog fight but with
dogs from three different like yeah
right snoopy versus Marmaduke versus
underdog
Underdog versus the [ __ ] like an
underdog kills them all he's on drugs
he pops a pill and he goes crazy and
just [ __ ] wakes up the next morning
all the dogs are
he's covered in blood he's like not
again then he flies away
um let's see man
um three archers
Oliver Queen
Legolas
and uh Hawkeye
all shooting each other in the [ __ ]
face
nice
[Music]
uh all right all going for eye shots
each one trying to take out the other
one's eye and so chip chip
they all lose their eyes and then we'll
find out who the best Archer is because
whoever's left
with one eye that's the that's the best
Archer
okay was it meant to be a fight
I think so
right JC really hurt it hurt when you
said snoopy versus Marmaduke I'm like
yeah Team Up movie slash fighting the
villain
oh so you have to identify the villain
also is the villain have to be another
Archer
it's just their verse movie I think like
Batman v Superman just they can all they
can end up as friends at the end maybe
one of them doesn't
Benjamin that says Thanos versus Family
Circus
okay
uh what do you got mark
um I kind of people are saying Legolas
would win what the [ __ ]
he was fast though in that movie
remember he was like she was I mean it
helps when you're firing CG arrows
um I think I I initially wanted to go
some [ __ ] Kaiju thing but there are
not enough kaijus that I think make
enough recognizable sense
so instead I'm going to go
um
Caster Troy
versus
sailor
versus
um
[ __ ] what the hell is his name in that
in Conair
basically it's all the necklace cages
you're building a steel cage match man a
steel cage he's surrounded by cages and
then the uh the villain is Nick Cage
from unbearable weight of impossible
Talent or whatever the hell the name of
that movie is
so yes it is the enter the cage
Cameron Poe Cameron Poe Caster Troy
and uh and sailor from Wild at Heart
that's good
did I ever tell you hey my snake skin
jacket I never tell you this jacket
represents mob what is it my my
individuality and my belief in personal
freedom only about a thousand times
foreign
you do a good Lord Dern thank you yeah
that makes me want to watch that movie
but that's not available on home video
is it is it not
hey Josh
can you find Wild at Heart
watch that [ __ ]
who's that
uh so yeah that's that's my that's my
pick for the verses
there it is
um what about you bath man
bat
Dracula and The Count from Sesame Street
oh [ __ ]
I'm in
[ __ ] account is just like
190 dead bodies
191 he's just counting the corpses man
body count body count
he's like the um the announcer like it's
uh like it's a k like it's an actual
cage match and he's the announcer
when you throw in count calculus uh
green star says Jane sound Bob plus
Method Man and red man plus Cheech and
Chong shouldn't should have chose that
much I mean it was just sitting there
it's right right there ready to be
sparked
um man that's a good ass question
all right number three is gonna take us
out of 2022. all right last last
question Andrew Shannon uh what are you
most excited for in the new year
uh your work and not your work like what
are you most excited for and then that
you're working on and then what are you
most looking forward to that somebody
else is gonna do
um I got a bunch of things for the first
few months of the year I'm just writing
um I got a bunch of writing projects
um for other
people so I unfortunately not at Liberty
to reveal but some of them are [ __ ]
wonderful and um
that's you know a different Beast than
the stuff that I do for myself
um
I'm most looking forward to because
we're seeing some traction on Mallrats
two Twilight of the Mall Rats so
fingers crossed because we heard from
the Lion's gate folks they're very happy
with Clerk's the performance of Clerks
three not allowed to say anything else
Jordan's always like I can't tell you
anything because then you talk about it
and you're talking to you but uh yeah
things looking good so it could be this
could be the you
uh that uh
we return to the mall y'all
uh and what am I most looking forward to
uh Quantum Mania man
the beginning of Kang the Conqueror
can't wait looks [ __ ] badass I I hope
it looks bleak I think some bad [ __ ]
happens to Ant-Man at the end and I'm
here for it I love Paul Wall [ __ ] I'm
ready to see [ __ ] Ant-Man face
faces trial as he deals with Kang
um what else is coming that I'm looking
forward to
uh Masters of the Universe uh season two
I don't wanna I don't want to be
destroyed on the internet so but I am
looking forward to it I've seen it and I
like what we're doing
um what else am I looking forward to got
more comic books coming kids
quick stops and masquerade the whole
like next four issues of masquerade be
coming this year early and then quick
stops maybe that pillow pants cover
continues to happen you can't stop it
there's an Elias cover right there
and look at that [ __ ] intricate cover
it's the entire story of [ __ ] Clerks
2 done in tiny ass little boxes
little boxes on a comic book
um so masquerade uh issues five through
eight come out and then quick stops
um the next four come out and uh also me
and Jeremy Simpson are working on
uh something a new book that
[ __ ]
love man I think it's so tight it's a
really good idea
um and he's almost done with the draw on
the first book
um it's pretty pretty sweet so I look
forward to that
um
over to you
um things I'm looking forward to seeing
I I cannot wait for
um across the spider verse uh when we
get part one uh later this summer
can't [ __ ] wait for that I cannot
wait for Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one because I will watch
Tom Cruise try to kill himself from my
money now that Jackie Chan isn't doing
it Tom Cruise is taking over the how
much will it cost me in pain to sell you
a movie ticket
plus he's still a good actor really
great actor only do you get a really
great time from Cruise performance but
he's like look at this [ __ ] for my next
trick
becoming Daffy Duck in that one [ __ ]
Merry Melody where [ __ ] him and bugs
are trying to outdo each other it's
dynamite and [ __ ] acid and [ __ ] and
blows up
there's a trailer before uh Avatar 2
when I saw an IMAX that I think it's on
the internet at this point but it's Tom
Cruise showing you how he's going to
jump Snake Canyon it's like this is the
ramp that we built that I'm gonna ride a
motorcycle off of it and then do a base
jump off the back of the motorcycle and
it's just showing you how he's doing a
[ __ ] stunt and it looks ridiculous
and the crowd lost its mind with just
joy and mirth and giddiness and watching
Tom Cruise throw himself off a mountain
and like you know what I'm here for that
level of Showmanship I'm here for that
level of commitment to earning my money
um so those are the two things over the
top of my head that I'm looking forward
to as opposed over to the things that
I'm looking forward to making
much like Kevin it's a it's a front
loaded writing year
um where there's there's a fair amount
of TV that needs to be written there are
some comic book stuff that needs to be
written
um there's some new stuff just for me
and we'll see what it turns into that
needs to be written
um but as opposed but for the things
that are going to come to stands that a
person could buy
census uh the book that I'm that I'm
doing for comixology will be collected
in the in the late winter early spring
by Dark Horse so those five issues will
be on comic book stands and in the
summer
um my Muhammad Ali biography Messenger
will be out from first second
um I think the pub date is August of
2023 and I've been working on that for
about 10 years and so we are finally
finally done and ready to unleash it
into the world
and so those are the things that I'm
pretty sure for now you can buy for next
year there may be more who can tell
um but yeah that's that's the hit list
at this point
um
Jason Muse and Jordan
um Monsanto
this good lady wife
um our welcoming a second child very
soon so in February I look forward to
boy Muse part two
um they haven't settled on the name yet
I'm voting for Magnus Magnus Muse that's
not something
but it's probably not going to be Magnus
but Jordan said you can call the table
whatever you want but that's not going
to be the kid's name
um I look forward to that I look forward
to uh The Rao Shaman in January at smog
Castle Clerk's open all night in
February the Ides of Mark the March when
we're gonna do fat man Beyond Live it's
modcastle Cinemas
what about
Indiana Jones we look forward to that
that's very true I forgot about Indy you
know what we did last week we watched
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
in the theater downstairs voluntarily
yeah you know what that movie actually
works man like I I realized as I watched
it I was like wow I fell asleep through
a lot of this [ __ ] like there's a lot of
that movie I never saw before in my life
you know it's like and I was sitting
there going oh man all this time out you
know I was one of those cats I was like
and I was like uh I looked at the date
to see when it came out [ __ ] 2008.
you know how old that movie is my kid
was nine when he came out she has her
own house now
like it happened what happened to the
time where did it all go Mark got its
own house I guess so but
um yeah it feels like a movie that gets
overly hated now man I think having I
was completely entertained and I also
wasn't like baffled like oh I was in the
theater I think I was baffled because I
fell asleep
woke up I was like was it are they going
to space or what I do still feel like it
should have been called Indiana Jones
and the saucer men from Mars I think
that's a hotter title than
but I'm looking forward to this new one
because I had such a good time watching
Crystal's call I was like I watch
[ __ ] Indiana Jones
to ride a horse in a Subway [ __ ]
spending too much time with Roush
okay
Josh was like we should watch it again
and uh I was like you know because it
can Liv his wife uh is like that's her
favorite of the Indiana Jones movie and
I was like what what are you nuts but
having just watched it I'm like it would
never be my favorite but like it holds
up it works
I mean I guess if it's your first
Indiana Jones movie then I get it
pops out to be like thank you
um yeah man I look forward to that what
else what's the other Marvel besides
quantumania they got another movie
I think so
I don't remember what it is
I guess the flash will also be next year
allegedly yeah I look forward to the
flash although
if Michael Keaton's might still be in it
did you guys see that that the flash
toys leaked and there is a a Michael
Keaton Batman toy that comes with a
flash toy with a a Batwing
did you guys see that pop up
it's a Batwing ship with a Ezra Miller
Flash and a Michael Keaton Batman toy
packaged
I just I I'm oh I know a lot of people
online and I'm gonna [ __ ] in my mouth
for this and I should probably just keep
my mouth [ __ ] shut but
man like I was looking forward to some
Michael Keaton Batman now it's good
times like I'm not saying he had to be
the one Batman of like the DC Universe
and [ __ ] but like
I hope they don't cut them all out in
Flash I hope there's I hope there's
stuff in there I hope there's a lot of
stuff here's here's the toy
let me see
Go full screen you did
oh my God
how big is that toy
scale was weird so it's like is Batman
this big or is Batman like a full eight
incher it he looks like a a like a four
inch Batman
okay what's uh who's making the toys
um gosh I can't
I can't see uh
I don't know it just says DC on it I
don't see the toy company
um Guardians three is next year also oh
my God yes oh [ __ ] uh yeah
that's why that's the one I gotta stay
alive for that's what's keeping my heart
pumping still I can't wait to see how he
sticks The Landing man oh my God yes
that trailer you know the trailer they
got out now is really great but the
trailer I saw Comic-Con was just [ __ ]
a religious experience man I can't wait
to see what he's doing with that movie
[ __ ] yes Guardians all day
as the kids say or used to I don't know
if they say anymore ours as the kids
used to say one
and apparently the Marvels is also next
year
I'm ready for that too
but
but come on [ __ ]
God damn it I want to see that [ __ ]
movie so fast
I want them all Marvel's my [ __ ] bag
man I know people are like you [ __ ]
they pay you they literally do not
um
I'm paid simply by enjoying the product
they put out
people like you said product
here's my wish for 2023 that I don't
have to pre-guess all the [ __ ] that
people are gonna give me for all the
[ __ ] that I I do and like
um I'm uh [ __ ] man that toy looked cool
come on don't like leave Michael keys in
that movie
I've been looking forward to that movie
for a long time solely for the Michael
Keaton aspect of it so come on man
come on Yucca fellas yum
um you know what
yeah nothing about it 2022 is almost
done you have any complaints I love 2022
for the most part like the uh 2022 is a
year of Clerks three for men you came
true took a long time to get there and I
was very satisfied with all the results
how was your 2022
um
fine
[Music]
you know there was there was some there
were some highs and there were some lows
I think it's everybody's was
um you know covet being a particular low
um
you know but I [ __ ] I got none Seth
Meyer so talk about a comic book so I
will always take that as well right I
was looking through my pictures these
[ __ ] gorgeous screenshots of you on
Seth Meyers and I remember that was cool
uh you know what I enjoyed my Seth
Meyers [ __ ] parents this year too we
were both on Seth Meyers not together
and I thought we both killed we did all
right I now have a goal for 2023. yeah
[Laughter]
yeah well next time we'll all do it
together we'll go as a crew
uh 2022 kids the year was not mid
2023 hopefully that will be Peak
give me the Peaks
all we want are the Peaks kids uh there
it is
from comic book store from Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash right here in
beautiful
downtown right back New Jersey
home of the comic book Man TV show at
one point well not this actual location
but the other one uh there it is there's
your fat man beyond there's your [ __ ]
fat man beyond for 2022. you were
looking for it here it was man a bunch
of people joined us tonight it's like 2
000 people won nice that'd be goddamn
New Year happy New Year everybody uh
make your New Year's resolutions and try
to stick to them kids uh remember
you made it to another year you know
sometimes this year was sad sometimes
this year was happy sometimes good
things happen sometimes negative things
happen but God damn it you made it all
the way through pour one out for all
those cats who didn't make it the trip
with us man the folks uh we left behind
in the human race but the rest of us are
still here still standing and heading
into 2023. uh smod bless us everyone
keep shining
me
that's for sure
that's what friends are for
ah there it is man we don't have a show
without the two individuals on the
screen who aren't me Banff man he races
like [ __ ] Quicksilver and the Marvel
Cinema Universe version of the character
uh to make sure this show happens for
you and stuff give it up for Banff man
and then of course the other guy sitting
in the Millennium Falcon will [ __ ] there
ain't no show without him everyone give
it up for marvelous Mark Bernard and
everybody thank you Kev so sweet peace
on Earth The Good Will toward every
[ __ ] buddy uh and uh enjoy your New
Year's safely kids get home in one piece
and [ __ ] party but like you know
don't [ __ ] handle your [ __ ] high
you know yes
there it is kids for 2022 from 2022 if
you're watching this in the future hello
from 2022
uh the end of 2022. uh this has been fat
man beyond man I'm uh Kevin Smith and
I'm Mark Bernard tune in next time same
fat Time same fat chance modcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith let's give 2022
uh ample Jeff's kiss
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]